Couple of other things are looking at
the previous example that I just showed
you that we should make concrete.
A good function for steel detection
has one stable, sharp beat.
For example, again the same
function that we looked at, f.
And if I was actually to trace this out,
this is not a peak here.
This would be problematic.
Here it has multiple peaks,
would be problematic because I
wouldn't know which scale to choose.
This is the kind of behavior you want.
You want to be able to kind of see
as the region size gets bigger,
this function basically
gives me one peak.
Again, some of the ideas here basically
suggest that we can actually do this for
most normal images.
A good function would be the one
that responds to the contrast or
intensity changes in an image.
I'm aware all of this still
sounds a little abstract, so
let's look at a few examples
to make this a bit concrete.
Here is an example of the same
building at two different scales.
In the case, this is an example of
a zoomed up image, and now zoomed out.
Here basically look at the scale and
basically we look at the function.
This a nice peak here.
This is the one we want to look at.
And at the same scale level,
this is visible at this point.
So in essence, now we need the two
scales for these two images.
This allows us to look at scale, and
actually model the scale that will allow
us to make our detector
invariant to scale